mais pour revenir à un problème
franco-fançais parce que je suis pas
d'accord avec laave de se dire on va
parler du conflit israë-palestinien les
amis on a évité de parler de parler du
conflit israë-palestinien parce qu'on a
parlé d'autres conflits on a parlé de la
guerre en Ukraine les Arméniens à
l'heure où je vous parle ça va pas mieux
mais moi mon indignation ouis je suis
musulman mais je suis père de famille je
suis frère je suis père quand je vois
les images de samedi mon indignation
c'est celle d'un gamin qui a grandi en
bonlieue parisienne pardon dans la même
école que vous vous croyez que moi je
suis allé dans une dans une autre école
O m'a dit fallait détester les juifs ou
les blancs non j'ai la même émotion que
vous au même moment et c'est valable et
pardon et je le dis je ne supporte plus
les injonctions fait aux musulmans sur
les plateaux télé où à chaque fois qu'il
y a un événement qui inclut un pseudo
musulman qu'on soit là en train de dire
mais c'est pas la même chose que nous je
suis venu vous le dire pour le Bataclan
je suis venu vous le dire pour Mohamed
Mera maintenant je vous le dis sur le
proche orient est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que dans un pays qui a été plus
touché que les autres je rappelle que
l'école de qui a attaqué Mohamed Mera
vous avez pas besoin de me dire c'est
une école juive ça m'a touché et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait Mohamed Mera
derrière pour jeter l'pr sur les
Palestiniens il dit je fais ça pour la
cause palestinienne qu'est-ce qu'il
disent les Palestiniens ça va aller on n
pas besoin de toi donc c'est pour ça que
je vous dis aujourd'hui à moins que mon
cher Cyril était transféré à har que
c'est le dessous des cartes nous n'avons
pas les éléments ici pour parler de
manière sereine d'un conflit qui est
aujourd'hui malheureux qui a grandi avec
nous et pardon pardon mais personne
autour de cette pas plus amisend diom
pas à la fois dans le même discours dire
on parle pas assez du conflit
israëlopalestinien et en même temps dire
ici on n pas à le faire parce qu'on a
pas les clés parce que pas et cetera il
y a des peuples qui sont autorisés à ce
qu'on leur parle et d'autres à ce qu'on
ne leur parle pas des public en résumé
oui en résumé oui fait Mo il y a des
vrais problèmes d'ORL est-ce que j'ai
dit ça oui si
vous non oui c'est ce que vous dites
mais si c'est ce que vous dites si vous
avez dit ici alors on pas sur qu même F
la condescendance de vouloir me faire
dire ce que j'ai pas dit je rép on pas
on pas je te le dis à toi ça fait un
mois que je te regarde tu as pas les
clés mon ami ouais ben peut-être et ben
moi je seraaiis ravi d'avoir un débat
avec toi parce que là par exemple tu as
dit plein de conneries plein de
conneries mais qui es-tu pour juger de
dire c'est des conneries ou
pasure la posture qui est la tienne
comme beaucoup de gens dans les les
médias français de faire non pas venir
un musulman mais de faire venir votre
musulman de faire venir des chalgoumis
de faire venir des gens que vous déz à
dire oui mais ça c'est la parole
musulmane chgoui ne représente qu'à lui
que lui alors je viens d'apprendre avec
beaucoup d'émotion
j le FC
musul ne représente que sa parole comme
moi je représente
que
bienven l'idée de dire et je
diszourssz discours très violent je
comprends
pas vous commencez par dire en fait il
faudrait qu'on soit tous unis que je
trouve formidable et après vous nous
expliquez qu'en fait votre place elle
était pas à cette à cette
manifestation non mais les amis je vous
ai dit aujourd'hui de manière risquée si
je me rends à une manif comme celle-ci
où je pense que l'entièrté des gens qui
étaient au Trocadero sont venus dans un
esprit de paix de d'échange et de
fraternité les amis aujourd'hui c'est la
guerre des images attends Valérie je
vais juste au bout c'est juste un moment
la guerre des images j'y vais avec une
bonne intention on m'insulte on me fait
quelque chose la guerre des images est
celle de regarder regarder ce qui s'est
passé applaudi attendez non mais juste
je l pas dans les Mar de mais juste pour
aller plus loin que ça quand madame
Alimi est décédée il y a eu un
rassemblement oui et ça m'a affecté j'ai
vu son fils passer à la télé mais parce
que je suis devant la télé j'ai une
émotion et je me dis j'aimerais bien y
aller c'està-dire je lis même pas à la
question du conflit isralpalestinien ça
m'affecte de me dire il y a pas de
Muslim et ils vont encore dire ouais ils
sont pas là mais ça ça traîne depuis
quand depuis Charlie Hebdo quand il la
manif je suis Charlie au lieu de se dire
c'est une belle manif on était en train
de se dire qui est là qui n'est pas là
les amis manif on y'y va pas pour voir
qui est qui n'y est pas on voit comment
aujourd'hui nous français puisque nous
avons la plus grande communauté
musulmane et la plus grande communauté
juive d'Europe comment ce pays où nous
étions mélangés sur les photos de classe
où on était fier d'avoir un copain qui
s'appelle David Mohamed Stéphane ù on on
s'envoie mais moi je déteste dire ça
mais on s'envoie des messages pour les
fêtes je vais pas outer les messages que
j'envoie avec Ciril c'est mieux pour
l'humanité mais il m'envoie des fêtes
quand c'est des messages pour ma fête et
je lui envoie moi vous croyez que ça me
fait plaisir quand je reçois le message
d'un ami juif qui me dit Yassine j'ai
mis ma musza chez moi pas dehors ça
m'affecte parce que je n'aime pas que
quelqu'un qui est proche de moi soit
affecté mais ça m'affecte mais là où je
comprends pas et vraiment je vous le dis
c'est que là depuis samedi je pense que
tout le monde a fausse route et vous
êtes pas les premiers c'est que quand je
regarde les chaînes d'info en continu
qui sollicite l'émotion et qui se pose
pas la question du second temps qui est
celui de dire mais les amis les
musulmans et les juifs ils vont rester
dans ce pays-là et moi la solution que
je propose c'est que vraiment on soit
aussi autour de la table pour dire venez
on envoie un message clair au
ProcheOrient qui est celui de dire nous
en France on le vit on le vit bien ça
n'enlève pas les actes antisémites et ça
n'enlève pas les actes islamophobe mais
Valérie mais ce que tu dis je comprends
pas où tu veux en venir parce que ce que
tu dis on le dit donc ce que tu dis
quand tu dis pe dire non mais oui mais
tu es en train de on a l'impression que
tu reproches un truc qui pourtant se dit
tu dis tu reproches en fait le temps de
l'émotion pardon il faut bien un temps
de l'émotion et tu dis il faut qu'on
parle du second temps on va y venir et
on est en train d'y venir il y a un
second temps effectivement pour cette
PAI tat là tu es en train de nous
reprocher le tempsm je reproche pas je
Valérie tu tu as vécu quelque chose et
tu m'as il y a un an il s'est passé
quelque chose sur le plateau je peux me
permettre d'en parler parce que ça m'a
beaucoup marqué durant l'enregistrement
d'une émission un chroniqueur dont je
tiraai le nom tu te souviens ce qu'il
m'a fait il m'a accusé d'antisémitisme
vous étiez là toi Floriant je
n'oublierai jamais ce qui s'est passé ce
jour-là al lui c'est Guillaume Guillaume
pardon et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'en
parle avec émotion c'était durant un
enregistrement je ressasse ça depuis un
an avec cy j'ai pas de problème à le
dire on s'est fâché pendant 2 mois on se
parlait plus tellement j'ai été choqué
je suis resté chez moi je me suis dit
regarde on m'a traité d'antisémite sur
un plateau télé heureusement c'était
enregistré tu sais ma ma grande émotion
Valérie je vais t'expliquer ce soir-là
c'est que tu as pris ma défense tu avais
dit quelque chose qui est marqué dans ma
tête à tout jamais Yassine on t'a
souvent accusé d'antisémitisme et vu ta
réaction j'ai compris que tu ne l'étais
pas moi ce que je vous propose ce soir
les amis c'est que en fait on va
échanger nos luttes que aujourd'
auourd'h est égal à 1 quand un Israélien
meurt ça nous peine comme quand un
Palestinien
Meur j'ai pas dit tu l'as pas mais c'est
quand même parce que tu avec un discours
extrêmement violent où tu nous accuses
grosso
modo dis collectivement c'est pas
mole tout à l'heure tu dis on n pas sur
pourquoi on discute du sous prétex que
tu as fait de documentaires toi tu es
plus brillant que les autres mais
pourquoi quel rapport ça avec ma
carrière rapport je te dis mon ami
depuis tout à l'heure tu me fais dire
des mots et c'est exactement c'est que
tu as dit à Cyril on n pas sur haré
pourquoi on parle Israël palestinien il
y a un point avec lequel je suis
d'accord alors permets-moi de le dire
vas-y c'est que et c'est très important
c'est que on ne parle de ce conflit
israëlo-palestinien que lorsqu'il y a
des grands événements comme celui-là
tragique et je pense que c'est une faute
de la part des médias de masse je parle
pas de cette émission mais je parle de
je parle de de l'endroit d'où je viens
service public et je là alors là sur 30
ans et je risque pas d'être contredit
où la couverture de l'événement
israëlpalestinien n'a fait que baisser
parce que et pour défendre mes camarades
aussi c'est aussi parce que c'est un
conflit qui dure depuis tellement
longtemps qu'il y a une forme de
lassitude et plus personne ne veut
comprendre et plus personne ne veut s'y
intéresser je suis d'accord avec toi sur
le fait que c'est une faute globale des
médias de masse et que les médias de
masse doivent absolument expliquer les
tenants les aboutissants beaucoup mieux
que que je ne pourrais le faire puisque
c'est ce que tu as l'air de dire mais
mais tu peux pas en même temps dans le
même discours nous dire vous n'avez pas
le droit d'en parler alors qu'il fait 2
millions de spectateurs 2 millions de
téléspectateurs tous les soir il y a des
gens c'est comme ça l'information elle a
changé il y a pas que les gens qui
regardent le 20h il y a des gens qui ne
s'informment qu'avec cette émission
c'est important de leur donner des clés
d'avoir un débat peut-être très cvant je
je je reconnais qu'il est très cvant ce
débat mais il permet aussi à chacun
d'essayer de comprendre de mettre des
clés et son et donc je comprends pas en
fait où tu veux en
venirmo Y
dire je suis tout à fait d'accord je
suis pas là pour insulter une émission
pardon dans laquelle j'ai participé moi
je trouve que l'émission fait quelque
chose que les autres médias ne font pas
c'est qu'il parle à tout le monde et le
sentiment d'élitisme dans les médias
français donne lieu à une
incompréhension totale des Français à
l'égard des autres aujourd'hui je te dis
quand moi on me dit oui mais en Iran les
amis les Iraniens c'est des chites moi
je suis marocain d'origine et donc je
suis franco-marocain même j'ai ma
nationalité et je suis sunite je te dis
par exemple que je vais au Maroc depuis
quelques temps et que je vois des quarts
d'Israéliens puisqu'ils ont normalisé
leur relation je vais pas te dire moi 6
mois après oui mais tu sais je suis
assez d'accord avec un ami qui me disait
quelque chose Yassine depuis samedi les
gens qui disent oui mais c'est compliqué
d'amorcer la suite de la conversation il
faut non mais ça déjà je le dis en ça
fait partie des choses qu'on a dit ici
tu d'accord excuse-moi si tu veux vous
l'avez dit mais c'est pas parce que tu
l'as dit que je le répète pas mais
maintenant pour pour aller au bout de ça
et t'expliquer quelque chose c'est que
je suis pas en train de te dire que ce
que fait l'émission n'est pas bien cet
homme cyil Hanouna est un émotif et il
est concerné par le sujet ça touche dans
sa chair quand il convoque l'esprit de
son père qui est néanmoins quelqu'un de
respectable et de respecté tu sais c'est
quand même fou parce que moi les
réponses quand je vois sous mes mes
messages ouais mais les Juifs généralisé
je ne le veux pas pour les musulmans
pourquoi j'accepterai pour les Juifs je
veut dire que ce personnage à côté de
moi s'il devit être un des personnages
la vérité siement il serait pas Patrick
abitb il serait José Garcia parce qu'il
a une ascension parce qu'on vient tous
les deux de banlieu et que venir sur ce
plateau il l'a fait il a travaillé dur
et aujourd'hui c'est ça que je veux
retrouver c'est C esprit d'unité qu'on a
eu pendant des années qu'on a perdu
aujourd'hui tu parles à des gens qui
sont très touchés moi je vais dire
quelque chose tiens ce message quand tu
vient
ici parce que tout àheure onule
minut gross on est un pe d'accord dites
plus dans les médias mais ne dis pas tu
dois à qui que ce soit personne tu
parles de tu parles de débat sur les
stars jeis prend on va on vaevenenir
dans un instant Yassine on vaevenenir
dans un instant il y aura Sacha aussi
euh qui a pris